сьогодні Дай Боже ми Приймемо цих два
критично необхідних законопроєкти але ті
колеги цього залу які були 4 грудня на
волонтерському форумі де обговорювалися
питання безпілотників знають якою кров'ю
давалося це питання де представник
держспецца експорт-контролю
місяцями не відповідав на прохання
волонтерів зустрітися і розглянути
питання подвійного призначення магіків
не відповідав на повідомлення і від
депутатів та інших представників уже
владних структур і коли ми на митниці
зокрема польський почали розбиратися А
чому мав які не пускають в Україну на
Польській стороні працівники нам сказали
що це на запит української сторони тому
коли ми зараз будемо знімати ці
обмеження встановлювати режим сприяння
завезенню такою необхідною техніки якою
є різного типу безпілотників коптери
тепловізійні приціли різне інша оптика
Ми маємо також можливо від парламенту а
можливо від інших структур звертатися і
до польської до словацької сторони щоб
ми полегшили процес завезення це тієї
техніки і її не зупиняли на
українсько-польському чи
українсько-словацькому кордоні як на
жаль зараз відбувається у десятках форм
які чекають своєї поїздки на передову І
хотілося би наголосити в той час коли
українське чиновники все це блокували
саме Сьогодні у нас є новий вимір війни
коли оптика і дрони є критично
необхідними я хочу подякувати зокрема
справі громади фонду Порошенка які себе
завезли і передали тисячі коптерів і
зокрема спеціальних комплексів Посейдон
на передову теж з перешкодами А ще
закликаю одноразові зарплати перед за
один день перерахувати на закупівлю коп